hier la veuve du préfet de corse claude
erignac assassiné en février 98
s'interrogeait dans un communiqué à
l'agencé france presse sur le remue
ménage entre policiers et juges dans l'
enquête sur cet assassinat cette
polémique agace manifestement mise
l'intérieur reportage michèle fines et
jérôme soûlard
sait depuis longtemps une rumeur c'est
devenu une certitude
ces deux hommes se détestent
pourtant ils travaillent ensemble ils
sont co saisi dans l'enquêté sur
l'assassinât du préfet erignac d'un côté
le très médiatique jean louis bruguière
pionniers de l'antiterrorisme de l'autre
gilberte il un juge venue de nancy
depuis son arrivée en 1995 au sein du
pool antiterroriste l'ambiance n'est pas
au beau fixe c'est une fuite au niveau
de l' enquête qui a tout déclenché il y
a quinze jours le canard enchaîné et
l'est républicain publie les extraits
d'un rapport de police le parquet de
paris ouvre immédiatement une
information judiciaire recel de
violation du secret de l'instruction
en clair un juge est chargé de trouver
d'où vient la fuite au sein du pool
antiterroriste l'heure est aux soupçons
la sphère revient sur la place publique
hier la famille erignac a fini par
demander dans un communiqué que les
juges ou blizzard querelle il faut que
les gens travaillent ensemble se fasse
confiance et il est clair que si les
magistrats ne travaille pas main dans la
main entre d'abord puis ensuite avec les
services de police on n'aboutira jamais
je crois qu'il faut que chacun prenne
ses responsabilités chacun reprenne son
calme et la famille ne demande que cela
à la sortie du conseil des ministres ce
matin jean pierre chevènement était
aussi cette polémique est regrettable il
y a à l'intérieur et un seul c'est
l'intérêt de l'enquète et de son
aboutissement tout le reste est
subalterne voire nuisible jean louis
bruguière gilberte il est laurence le
vert le troisième juge chargé de
l'enquêté tous ont été entendus au
palais de justice à magistrat recherche
toujours l'auteur de la fuite